[Music]
so of course you have a leverage thing
where I focus on between is NASA to see
that boy I dropped my own person you see
but that's not like you know that's just
a leverage he's strong enough I won't be
able to do it okay it's like I have a
lever to move a rock it'll work
the monster rocks heavier than I can
generate force with that okay I'm not
doing that if you look at complexity why
I'm using his grid to make his body do
something the temptation you think
there's a second hand isn't it but for
the beginner Bart
okay but you're still doing the first
step and you're still
[Music]
he's supposed to push guess you
understand he's supposed to have a
social degree of penetration so you push
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hold on hold on hold on it's not fluffy
he's just not llaman yo you got it so if
you try doing this then I use that
integrity
[Music]
CVV nugget we can meet kuzey she is the
Bach outward spider so make sure you
Center is still doing this fire to
movement so you're not gonna like this
summer to get on the Kazushi flower
oh don't forget there is a cold okay but
it's also what sets my shoulder hasta
come out line job halfway in okay so the
elbow started young and must go in well
when you guys use your beverage you
leave that elbow in the online type if
you bring that happens leave that down
there I've moved the elbow to the in
line here it's out my shoulder and
you're going like that to try to get it
instead bring the elbow to the in mind
then it can go back to young okay so my
elbow and then it's going to come
through the yin line Oh
sure got it on this half will be young
on the other side got it don't leave it
out there then go like that